I love flawed characters I think flawed
characters are really interesting and
more interesting to play them out and
out nice characters nobody really wants
to see a nice character all the time
because it's just boring and vanilla and
I hate vanilla in the nervous kind of
the worst thing to play really so I
don't like characters that are that
facilitate like the actors in the show
or the piece so they're not just there
to kind of make the actor look good or
to just be there to kind of feed him his
comedy lines essentially I like somebody
with a bit of an edge and somebody who
has a bit of a past or something that I
can you know that I can make a past for
and I think you know the last couple of
roles I've done like with casts and mr.
Selfridge and Sherlock they've all had
they've all been flawed and they've all
been kind of vulnerable and interesting
I think my most challenging role is yet
to come about to do the 40th anniversary
of Abigail's party non-playing Beverley
and I think that for me is it's going to
be a real challenge because she's kind
of an iconic character and it's an
iconic play and it's such a specific
role and it's been made famous by the
glorious Alison Steadman it's very
difficult to put your own stamp on it
you know it's so difficult to because
it's all in the text so you know her
voice and her take on it is in it is in
the text so so I think that's going to
be quite a tricky thing for me it is
daunting working on a series like Cheryl
or yes it's quite overwhelming because
the fan base is so strong and so
protective and so fiercely protective of
it if you don't do it to the best of
your ability you kind of feel like
you're letting everybody and I'm I don't
want to let any of these fans down
because they are invested in it it's a
really nice feeling knowing that there
is that love and that warmth for all
these characters and they love they do
genuinely love them and I know
everything about them which is
astonishing really well the role of Mary
came to me in Margate is his kitchen and
we just watched the hounds of
Baskerville and they were talking about
the third series and I saw was sitting
in listening to it and thinking this
sounds kind of thing and then they came
to they said well that we're going to in
we're going to introduce Mary Morstan I
thought that sounds great what you know
it's brilliant and they said what do you
think and I was thinking well I think
Nikola walk would be amazing for that
and I think now I was thinking all these
people that could play her and I said no
no we'd like you to do it and I kind of
went oh really
Wow and I kind of got a bit upset like
emotional because I'm always verging
they said no we would like you to play
what do you think and I said yeah yeah
I'll do that that's fine there is a
family atmosphere on the set we all get
on really well it's a hard shoot because
it's a thick script is a lot of stuff to
do in it and you have to be on top of
your lines and you have to be on top of
your day so the fact that we all get on
it helps with the day-to-day running of
the scenes and getting through them but
that's like with any television job with
it you get thrown together with these
people and you kind of have to get on
that's that's the key you know you have
to be a team player if you're working on
anything in the theatre in the film in
film or television I think you have to
be turn up on time know your lines and
be easy to work with they're my three
kind of main mantras I think if you
can't do that then I don't think you're
an actor I don't think you're an actor I
think you're just turning up and wanting
to be in wanting the fame or the
adulation turn on the time learn your
lines be easy to work with and then you
know whatever happens next is a bonus
really if I get that cool and I go
you've got it I'm like and then I have
to then I check to see how many days I'm
working because I have two children so I
have to kind of manage that and then
I'll reread the script
about four or five times a reader
scripts a lot before the read-through
usually and then if it's a period piece
or if it's a piece where it's a real
person and I'll find out about them if
it's a fictional character then I shall
start to just work out my points of like
what she's done where she's come from
and like this could all be nonsense you
know because the director could have
another idea but I just think it's good
to come with some sort of vague idea of
what you feel the characters because
you've been picked and then I learn I
usually learn it the night before
because it goes in and then I have
another look in the morning and if I
don't learn the whole thing I can't
return television lines theater one if
you can and use a different part of your
brain but television
so immediately does for me when I'm
doing a play and I think it's because
you're doing the same thing over and
over again and you're in a rehearsal
room you're doing 8 9 hours a day the
difficult of your brain kicks in and get
all this is I've got to retain me
whereas when I'm doing television or
film I just get rid of it has to go
because the next day I'm doing something
different and actors should be a sponger
nation to take everything they can from
everyone
and use it and just log it in and that's
what I do on every job I'll kind of
learn something from a director or
another actor and I think I like the way
they've done that or that's interesting
on that of manipulate that into my own
way of doing it the more you do the more
confident you become and you have to be
confident without being arrogant it's
very important the hardest thing about
the job is not working I think that's
the hardest thing and there's that
euphoria of going are kind I've got I've
got some time off now and that's really
short-lived it really is because you
just go right and this has been like
it's been quite a while now and it's
only been like four weeks or five weeks
I need to do something else now that's
it I think and you're kind of acting
muscle stuff stuff it'll flex a bit and
you start thinking what what's the next
thing and because I'm sometimes glass
very much half-empty I go well that's
all washed up now I'm not doing anymore
that's it all done so you have to kind
of be positive I think sometimes actors
let let it control them whereas you have
to be in control of it you have to be in
control of your career and you have to
be in control of how you deal with
rejection and how you deal with not
working you know you have to fill that
time and use it wisely I think it's
incredibly important to support new
talent and especially kind of
working-class kids who haven't done had
the opportunity to go to drama school I
think they need a leg up more than
anything because they know this
incredible talent out there my one solid
piece of advice to anyone who wants to
become an actor is work hard be nice be
somebody who people want to work with
this is loads of pieces of advice and
don't give up don't give up because if
it's in you if
sinuan if it's in here and it's in here
then your your lack your like however
wherever you go you will do it but I
just need to see you have to yes just
dig your heels in and keep going
[Music]